[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome episode number 78
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am
resplendent today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You're resplendent.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Right, good.
I'm OK.
MARK MANDEL: You're
OK, you're just fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm just OK.
I'm just fine.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
No, I'm actually
very happy because we have
finally the two co-founders
of Firebase, James
Tamplin and Andrew Lee
are visiting us to tell us
everything about Firebase
and specifically,
everything that
was announced during Google
I/O that small conference
that took place last week.
MARK MANDEL: So I actually
don't think they're
going to tell us everything.
Just because there
was so much, I
don't think they could fit
it in the time that we have.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually there
was a lot of things going on,
so yeah, they're going to
tell us their favorite things.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
It's a very
interesting interview.
And then at the
end of the episode,
we have a Question
of the Week about how
to give someone a Google
Cloud Platform project.
If I had a project and I
wanted to give it to you,
how does that even work?
But before that, we're going to
have Cool Things of the Week.
And there's actually, if you
want Cool Things of the Week,
I'd say go check
Google I/O's keynotes.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because there
was a lot of content in there.
So one of things that I
think we should highlight
is the Google Cloud TPUs.
So a TPU is like a CPU or a
GPU But CPU uses for computing
and G is for graphics,
T is for Tensor Flow.
And they were designed a
long time ago actually.
But we finally have them
available on Google Cloud.
And they're pretty
amazing because they're
able to provide 180 terabytes--
no, not terabytes, teraflops.
MARK MANDEL: That's more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is a lot.
MARK MANDEL: And those
are different numbers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a
completely different thing.
And a FLOP, it is not
something that falls.
It is floating
operation, so FLOPS
is floating
operations per second,
and 180 terabytes
is a lot of them.
And on top of that,
they're connected
to memory that is accessible
through a very, very
large bandwidth.
You can communicate
with the memory
at 12.5 gigabytes per
second, which is crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, you're going
to be able to do some
really cool processing.
I think that for
machine learning,
this is going to be huge.
If you're running any
TensorFlow or probably
any other processing that makes
sense to run as TensorFlow,
machine learning, image
processing probably also helps.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's pretty--
I mean, I'm just reading
the blog post here
and they're talking
about how what
used to take a full day to train
on 32 of the best commercially
available GPUs, would take a
full day to process some data.
Now it trains the same accuracy
in an afternoon just using
one eighth of a TPU pod.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is crazy.
Yeah, it is kind of
an amazing thing.
So we'll have a link to the
announcement on the show notes.
There's also a research
paper that was published,
and also there's pictures of
them and they're beautiful.
They actually kind of look like
actual cities with buildings.
It's pretty cool.
I really like them.
And I have not had the
chance to play with them yet,
but I'm actually
learning TensorFlow now.
So hopefully I will be able to
compare how much faster they
are compared to my Mac.
MARK MANDEL: Probably
a lot faster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Probably a lot, yes.
Hopefully.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And so for a second
cool thing of the week,
if you listened into
any of the stuff at I/O
and you're into the
Internet of Things,
there is now a whole new
product, the Google Cloud IoT
Core for managing and securely
connecting to Internet
of Thing devices at scale.
What this means is,
it's quite nice,
is that there's really
nice, fast set up
and management for when
you want to be sending data
from your IoT
devices back to, say,
analytics platforms or
processing platforms.
Specifically even things
like dataflow at pubsub,
or even cloud
functions, that we have
this product that now, out of
the box, is able to do that.
What's super cool
about it too is
it's auto-managed
infrastructure.
So, much like App Engine
will scale by itself,
this is a fully managed,
pay as you go GCP service,
so you don't have to worry
about how it scales out
to handle the load.
It's meant to connect
up to millions
of globally dispersed devices.
So I think that's pretty awesome
if you're into the IoT space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That actually
sounds pretty amazing.
Very useful.
So I guess that since
the episode today,
we're going to be
covering so much,
it's time to go talk to
our friends from Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
let's go do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm very, very happy
to welcome today the two
co-founders of Firebase,
James Tamplin and Andrew Lee.
Hello, how are you doing?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Good,
thank you for having us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
It's really a pleasure.
We were actually waiting to
have you for quite a while,
but finally you accepted
because there was a good reason.
Google I/O, I think it happened
last week or something.
JAMES TAMPLIN:
Something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
something like that.
I heard about it.
I don't know.
Unfortunately Mark and I
were not able to be there,
but hopefully you're going
to be able to catch us up
on all the cool things that
you were announcing there.
Before doing that,
though, why don't you
tell us a little bit about
what you do at Google?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Cool.
So, I'm James.
I am the product
manager for Firebase
and specifically Firebase's
back end services.
So we provide a
bunch of tools that
lets you build applications
without needing
to worry about servers
or manage infrastructure.
A lot of that is tying in
with Google Cloud Platform.
So we provide a
lot of great tools.
ANDREW LEE: Sure, I'm Andrew.
I'm James' counterpart
on the engineering side,
and I manage the team
up here in San Francisco
and partly in Mountain View
that works on the back end
services including,
like James said,
many of the cloud integrations.
MARK MANDEL: Why
don't we get a bigger
picture of what Firebase is?
If people haven't
played with Firebase,
they used to be sort of
like two or three things,
now know there's like
10, 20, 30, 50, 100,
I'm not sure anymore.
What are all the
things that Firebase
has that people
can take advantage
of in like one minute or less?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, from a
very, very high point of view,
what is Firebase,
what does it do?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So the tag line
is tools and infrastructure
to build better apps and
grow successful businesses.
So we started out as this
back end as a service
that I mentioned, build apps,
don't worry about servers,
don't worry about
infrastructure.
And those tools provided
functionality or infrastructure
that let you add functionality
to your application.
And so we we had the
real time database,
that was our first product, and
we had Firebase Authentication
and Firebase Hosting.
As time grew on,
we both expanded
that set of features and we
also added two more categories.
So the first is our
app quality products.
So we have Firebase
Crash Reporting,
we have Firebase
Test Lab, and we just
added a new product
that we'll talk about,
Firebase Performance Monitoring.
And then the third
category is tools
to help you grow your user base.
And we have a whole--
I think-- about 7
products in that area.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Kind of the same question
but from an engineering
point of view, is this
running on Google Cloud,
how does this work?
What is the relationship between
Firebase and Google Cloud
Platform?
ANDREW LEE: So it turns out
that Firebase and Google Cloud
Platform are actually
the exact same platform.
Under the hood they
share the same concept
of accounts, of projects, of
billing, so if you go today
and you create a Firebase
project it is, under the hood,
a cloud project.
And you can go over
to the cloud console
and you can see
the same projects,
you can manage the same
users, you can set up
the same information.
Which is really a
very powerful idea
because Firebase has a nice
set of products to kind of get
going on mobile and
web development,
but cloud has a much more
advanced and larger set
of tools for the more
advanced applications.
And so this gives
you a nice path.
You can start on
the Firebase, you
can get going with
your application,
and when you need the more
advanced or powerful features,
they are all available
from the same platform
without you needing to set up
a new account or a new project
or change your billing
profile or anything like that.
Its all right there with Google.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And we should
probably make mention
that we have had
previous episodes
talking about Firebase.
At least two or three.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We had Vikram,
we had Sara Robinson, we had--
MARK MANDEL: We had Abe come in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We had Abe.
We had, also, the one
that does skateboarding.
ANDREW LEE: David East?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: David
East, there you go.
So you know we've got
lots of episodes on--
ANDREW LEE: Skateboarding is
his main job here, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Skateboarding?
I just thought he was,
like, hurting himself
a lot by falling over.
ANDREW LEE: Professional
skateboarder.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's his job.
Secondly, there are some
things he talks about,
Firebase or something.
ANDREW LEE: Also that, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But we'll have a bunch of
links to all of those episodes
on the show notes.
So if you want to learn more
about it, just check them out.
ANDREW LEE: Awesome.
So we just finished
Google I/O. I'm
sure it's a big
relief to all of you.
Why don't we talk about
some of the new things that
came out of Google I/O?
We probably can't
go through them,
so let's pick some favorites.
James, you want to go first?
You want to pick a
favorite feature that's
come out during I/O know
that you want to talk about?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Super
quickly, I think
the one other thing that
your audience should know
is that Andrew
mentioned, that they
are the same platform
underneath the hood.
Firebase is targeted at kind
of client side application
developers.
So you're writing iOS, Android,
or for the web, while Google
Cloud largely focuses on the
back end, the infrastructure
developers.
So they really complement
each other nicely.
In terms of my favorite, or
some of my favorite launches,
I think one of the big ones is
phone number authentication.
So we have a product called
Firebase Authentication which
lets you easily
log in your users.
So we write a couple
of lines of code
and you can let them
log in with Facebook,
let them log in with Google,
Twitter, or GitHub, et cetera.
Username and password
or even connect
with your own existing
user account system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
is one of my favorite features
by the way.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yeah, no
messing with [INAUDIBLE],, it's
fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So we
had a lot of requests.
Especially from our users
in emerging markets,
where potentially they
don't have an email
address, or even in
developed markets
where there's just far
less friction with logging
in with the phone number.
And so last week we announced
that this is now possible.
So you can just prompt
a user to log in,
they enter their phone number,
we send them a text message.
And if you are on
Android, we even
do some pretty cool
special source,
where we'll automatically
read the text message
and log you in for a very,
very frictionless sign
up experience.
So yeah, it's, again,
you want your users
to be able to get
into applications,
start using the functionality
as quickly as possible.
And this is one of
the ways where we're
making that happen for you
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, OK, so
let's pick the second favorite.
Why don't you go now, Andrew.
ANDREW LEE: You know, I have to
go with the Hosting and Cloud
Functions integration.
This is something
I actually spoke
about, if you go
look on YouTube,
I gave a talk last Wednesday
talking about Firebase
and Google Cloud and our
Firebase Hosting plus Cloud
Functions integration
really opens up
an entirely new set
of possibilities
for using Firebase Hosting
and now for dynamic content.
For years we've done a great
job serving static assets
but there's a bunch
of limitations
around have static assets only.
And you can now build
really any sort web app
very easily without
having to worry
about the servers or scaling
using our Cloud Functions
integration.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm curious too,
because obviously you've had
integration with the Firebase
Realtime Database.
What functionality does that
give you above and beyond
like building a single page web
app using the Firebase Realtime
Database using Cloud Functions
on the web with the hosting?
What's the difference there?
ANDREW LEE: So it
turns out that there's
a number of very
common things you
might want to do that aren't
actually very possible using
a single page app.
So a good example of this,
which I demo-ed last Wednesday,
is social sharing.
When you say, tweet
out a link to your app,
Twitter is actually
going to go and they're
going to scrape that
page, and they're
going to pull off the
images so that they
can show a nice picture
for the user in that tweet.
And if you have a
single page app,
where the JavaScript
is doing the rendering,
Twitter might not be
able to pick that up.
And this is actually
a very common pattern
around the internet where if
you want someone else to be
looking at your page
and parsing the HTML,
it's much harder
if it's JavaScript.
And so you could actually
do that rendering
on our server side.
Do a pre-render and show that.
Another reason is
actually for performance.
For Firebase Hosting,
we provide a CDN
that caches your results
all over the world
and if you have a page
that's maybe something
that you want to render very
quickly on mobile phone,
or something that you want to
be like very high performance,
high scale, but for which
you want dynamic content,
you can use the Cloud
Functions to do your rendering.
And then you can use Firebase
Hosting to cache those results
at the edge.
And provide very quick response
without needing the end user's
device to download the page,
connect to the database,
download the data, and
then render things locally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
what does that look like
from the developer experience?
You have, the static
hosting, so you just
have like HTML and some
JavaScript in there,
and then you deploy
those functions,
and then you call them,
what does this look like?
ANDREW LEE: Yeah, there's
really two halves to it.
So part of it is setting up
the Cloud Function itself,
which is pretty simple.
You can use the Firebase
SDK for Cloud Functions
and the Firebase Command
Line Tool to write your code.
It's just node, so you can
use the whole node package
ecosystem, including
things like Express.
And we've actually built the
SDK to plug nicely into Express,
use the same types of
objects and things,
so you can get
going very quickly.
So in the case of hosting
[INAUDIBLE] functions,
you'd probably write some code
to render a page with Express
and then you'd go over to
your hosting configuration
and you'd connect certain paths,
certain urls over to functions.
And you'd say, with the
rewrite rule, you'd say,
this path should actually
be served by this function.
And then you say
Firebase Deploy,
we'll put the
functions up there,
we'll send that
configuration to hosting,
and we'll tie them together
for you behind the scenes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I actually saw your
talk at Google I/O.
We'll have a link to it.
It is really good.
I really love the fact that--
normally, when you see
people like co-founders,
they don't tend to
write much code.
So getting on
stage at Google I/O
and writing so much code,
like congratulations,
that was really good.
ANDREW LEE: You know, I have
to admit, I had to kind of dust
off my programming skills the
weekend before, including--
this was the first kind
of meaningful thing
I've done with TypeScript.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh cool.
ANDREW LEE: And so that's
kind of an exciting, fun thing
for me to learn a new language.
So I really enjoyed it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was very good.
We'll have a link to that
video from the show notes.
So definitely check it out.
Let's go for one more lunch.
What is your other favorite?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Sure so I
think my other favorite was
we started to open source our
SDKs, which developers have
been asking us to do for years.
And it was a very
exciting moment for me
and I think most of the team.
This is really
important because I
think it's a key part of the
Google Cloud Platform Strategy,
is openness.
Leading the way with things
like Kubernetes and TensorFlow
and projects throughout
the rest of Google.
So we were excited
to join in the fun.
So the big news here is
our iOS, our JavaScript,
and our admin, which are
kind of our service side
SDKs are now open source.
Specifically, the products
within them, those back end
service products that we were
talking about earlier are open.
And it's all on GitHub.
So our primary tool
chain is now GitHub.
So you can go and go
to GitHub.com/Firebase,
check out those SDKs, pull
requests against them,
and generally look at kind of
what we're doing and contribute
to it.
And we'd love for you
to go and do that.
I think in the past couple
days since we opened them up,
we've got one of our
community contributing patches
to help them build against OS X.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So, yeah.
Great to see the
community getting involved
and we're thrilled to
work with everyone.
MARK MANDEL: So now I'm
curious, because I've
going to ask this
question before he does.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I know
what you're going to ask.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you do.
So does that mean then
that if other people want
to write implementations
in other languages,
they can kind of use the
open source as a reference
and go from there?
JAMES TAMPLIN: They
won't be considered
official, completely supported,
you know, Firebase SDKs,
but yeah.
If you want a fork.
MARK MANDEL: So you can have Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, there's
actually a pretty decent Go
library for Firebase that
I've used a couple of times.
I think it's called Fire Go
and it works pretty well.
I don't think it covers
all of the features
that Firebase offers, though.
Any plans on supporting Go as
the main language that it is?
ANDREW LEE: Yeah, so I think one
of the things to keep in mind
is, on the admin side,
on the server side,
like James mentioned,
we have ambitions
to support really anything
that the developer might want.
We really want to meet the
developer where they are.
But that's a lot of work,
as you might imagine.
And so we focus our efforts
around the platforms that
tend to be more commonly used.
Do you'll notice that
our node SDK right now
is the most full-featured,
it covers most products.
We also have an SDK for
Java and obviously we
would love to do more things
in Go and other languages.
But today Node is
the most supported,
Java's kind of second, and
other things are coming.
But we're really going to be
investing a lot more, I think,
over the next year.
MARK MANDEL: Have you
considered a Pearl SDK?
ANDREW LEE: Haskell.
Haskell goes first.
MARK MANDEL: COBOL.
COBOL SDK.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Excellent
all right We'll
take that to the team.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
go we'll go one more.
What's your final
favorite there?
ANDREW LEE: I feel like we
didn't talk about Performance
Monitoring yet, did we?
I've got to mention that.
So this is the one new product.
Everything else we've
talked about here
is features on existing
products or new integrations,
but this is actually
a brand new product
from Firebase that lets
you, from your SDK,
do timings of network
requests and on anything else,
really, that you want
in your application,
to get a sense for how
your app is actually
performing in the wild.
And this is really important
because you, as a developer,
on the latest and greatest
phone on your Wi-Fi network
in your office, may not get a
good sense for what it actually
is like to be a
consumer on your app.
And this is the tool you really
need to be able to do that.
So this just launched
last week, it's brand new.
We've gotten some
really great reviews.
There's already been a
number of large customers
that launched it
since the event.
They heard about it and they put
it right in there right away.
And so I'm really excited to
see how this grows over time.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yeah, and it
will give you stock traces,
it will give you percentiles
on your latency and network
requests.
Yeah, it's a really cool tool.
I think a team has
done a lot of iteration
over the past couple
of months and I think
the UI is really intuitive.
So it doesn't cost
anything; completely free.
Comes turned on when you
use the Firebase SDK.
So if you haven't yet,
throw that into your app
and start going.
It's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that sounds super cool.
I'm guessing as varying
infrastructure happens
around the world and like
people's bandwidth is very,
very different, depending
on-- then you can really
see like performance metrics
based on where things are
and that kind of stuff.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Exactly, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
ANDREW LEE: So I'm going to
break the rules here and shout
out.
Just a couple of things
I want to talk about.
MARK MANDEL: Go on then.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Go for it.
ANDREW LEE: Is
we're really trying
to do a much better
job of supporting some
of the other languages
that maybe we
hadn't done quite as good as
job of supporting in the past.
So one of those is that
we're doubling down
our Swift support.
And we made a bunch
of improvements
to just kind of
usability and feel
of using the Firebase SDKs
in Swift, which is obviously
really critical iOS, which is
very important for Firebase
as a whole.
And then, similarly, we've
done a bunch of work on Unity
and c++.
And this actually
didn't launch at I/O
but it launched relatively
recently before,
so I think it's
worth mentioning.
But we're making a
big push into games
and trying to address
those markets too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it looks like you--
I mean, you expanded more
at I/O into games as well.
You opened up Game Support and
Test Lab as well, didn't you?
ANDREW LEE: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: And that's
super, super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So something
that is also pretty cool,
we use it all the time for all
of our projects, specifically
for Google Cloud Platform
Podcasts, is Google Analytics.
And it helps
understand what people
are doing with your web apps.
And it seems that there
is a new thing, which
is Google Analytics for
Firebase, which is specifically
for the applications that
you can build with Firebase.
Could you tell a little
bit more about that?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Certainly.
So a year ago at I/O
2016, we announced
a brand new analytics
product from Google
called Firebase Analytics.
In reality, the analytics
team helped us with this.
They did, you know,
98% of the work.
And and it's not actually a
brand new analytics product,
it's a native mobile
focused analytics product
from the Google Analytics team.
And it appears if you go
to analytics.google.com
and, you know, it also has a
view in the Firebase console.
And so we had a lot of
people over the course
of the last year being
like, which one do I use?
Google Analytics or
Firebase Analytics?
And we're like no, no, no.
It's all the same.
And so we're reflecting
that now by rebranding it
as Google Analytics
for Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what is the difference?
You said that it's
specifically centered
into mobile applications?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Exactly.
So Google Analytics,
the original version
was built in a web
focused world where
you had these kind of
sessions and page views.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And
so Google Analytics
for Firebase is,
since Firebase is
Google's mobile platform, has
iOS and Android SDKs number
one.
Number two is we've moved out
of that web page focused world
into a mobile focused world.
A lot more event data
is being generated.
So what we do is we
provide free unlimited,
unlike Google
Analytics where if you
hit a certain
number of events you
have to have to start paying.
And we do that by creating
what's called a rolling 30 day
base view.
So we basically keep every
single event for 30 days
and then we start aggregating.
And so that way where we're
able to provide this product
for free to whatever scale.
We have some of the biggest apps
in the world using the product.
And I think one of
the exciting things
that we also-- you know,
besides just the re-brand,
we announced a couple
of really cool things.
One is support for
Android Instant Apps which
is the ability to use an
application without actually
having to install it
from the Play Store.
So that's really cool if
you want introspection
to those apps.
And the other thing that I think
Google Cloud Platform customers
and developers are really
going to care about is we
partnered with the BigQuery
team to announce a 10 gigabyte
free storage TF BigQuery.
So now, you have to
enter a credit card,
but once you have
that credit card
and you can export from
Google Analytics Firebase
directly into BigQuery to
do much richer querying.
And as I said, after 30 days
we start doing some sampling
on that data.
And if you want to keep
it in its full fidelity
you can export it
out to BigQuery
and do all the querying
that your heart desires.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so that
means that actually now you
get the 10 gigabytes
of storage for free
plus one terabyte
per month of queries.
So that's a lot of processing.
That's very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that
gives people really
like a great opportunity
to play with the analytics
and see if they need
to use BigQuery.
Just try it out
to see if it works
or not without having to take
some charge upfront, which
is super nice.
ANDREW LEE: I'm excited about
it because the query is really
one of the hidden gems of GCP.
I don't know if
everyone understands
how powerful tool
this really is,
but it's really
really pretty amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is for me, it
is the best to
Google Cloud Platform
if you want to wow someone.
Like you just demo
little, little things.
Like just processing
a couple of terabytes
of data in a second
and their like, what?
So that's very easy.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So I have
actually an anecdote
for everyone.
So we, prior to joining Google,
used another data warehouse
solution to store and process
all of our stats pipelines
and analytics.
And when we joined
Google we were
required to move over to
GCP infrastructure, which
we did gladly.
And we moved from this
solution over to BigQuery.
And it decreased our query times
from about 60 seconds to 5.
So you know, I'd be sitting
there, you know click a button,
wait 60 seconds, see
the graph come up,
and it made me a lot
personally happier
and it was fantastic for the
rest of the team as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I guess
especially if the queries
that you're running, you're
actually debugging it.
And you're not sure if they're
going to give the good results.
Having to wait for one minute
to make sure that this works
or not, that sounds like a lot.
Yeah.
Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So
speaking of analytics,
there are a couple of
other things in here
I thought looked really
interesting, particularly
the Stream View
and the De-Bug View
to help people be able to
kind of see what's going on
inside their analytics.
Can you talk about those?
ANDREW LEE: Sure.
So those actually
launched a little bit ago.
They didn't come out at I/O
but I think they're exciting,
we're talking about--
so these are a couple
of additional tabs
under the Google Analytics
for Firebase section
of the console,
that one, gives you
a better idea of how
people around the world
are interacting with your app.
So it is kind of cool live map
showing what people are doing.
And then the De-Bug
View is really
intended to help you during
the installation phase
to get a sense for if your
app if your app is actually
correctly hooked
up to Analytics.
So generally with
Analytics, there's
a bit of a delay between
when the analytics are logged
and when they're reported.
And this is for battery
efficiency reasons.
We don't actually want to stream
everything down right away,
we want a kind of batch process.
But you don't actually want to
do that while you're setting up
the app.
You want to be able to have a
real fast de-bug cycle, so you
use De-Bug View to
get a sense for,
is my app configured correctly?
Am I logging the right
events, and then when you go
live you're much more
battery efficient.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We're kind of
running out of time
but there's a question
that I want to ask,
which is, OK so there was a
lot of cool things announced
at Google I/O. What's next?
JAMES TAMPLIN: I think
there's a couple of themes
at a high level.
The first theme is--
I think this is no secret
and Google is working
on this across the board--
is weaving machine
learning into our products.
So especially on the
growth side of Firebase,
being able to intelligently
recommend to developers actions
they can take to increase
their user base in the most
intelligent number of steps.
So I think that's one big one.
I think the other
big one to note,
that your listeners
will be interested in,
is deeper integration.
Continued integration with
Google Cloud Platform.
As Andrew mentioned
earlier, they
are the same under the hood.
You know, we share billing
accounts and projects
and all of those pieces.
And right now we have Cloud
Functions and Cloud Storage,
which are shared between
the two platforms
and you should expect more
exciting feature sharing
coming in the future.
And we've got a couple of things
in the pipeline that I cannot
wait to show the world.
And it's going to be
really, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well before we wrap
up, is there anything
we missed or something you
want to plug or mention?
Or anything really
going on that you think
is particularly
exciting, you make
sure the listeners hear about?
ANDREW LEE: I want to remind
everyone about Cloud Functions
because it's super cool.
I know we kind of touched on
it with Hosting and Functions.
This is actually a
new thing for us.
We launched the Cloud
Functions for Firebase in March
along with the public launch
of Cloud Functions in general,
and it is really slick.
So if you haven't
given the shot,
it lets you hook up
little snippets of code
to events throughout
the Google ecosystem.
So if you have a right
to your database,
if you have a
Pub/Sub event, if you
have a conversion
event and analytics,
all these can trigger code.
And it's run in a
managed way by Google,
it's automatically
scaled by Google,
and it makes it really
easy for you to get up
and running without
having to worry
about operations and scaling
and all of those things.
So this actually ties
nicely into what's next,
and I spoke about
this last Thursday
actually in one of
the fireside chats.
But I think you're
going to see a lot more
coming from Google
and Cloud Functions
with more integrations and
better tools and things
because we're really
excited about the space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
And if you want to learn
more about cloud functions,
we also had an episode
on cloud functions.
Episode number 73, we
have Brett McGowan.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So James, Andrew, thank you
so much for joining us today,
talking to us about Firebase.
Hot off the heels of I/O, and
so thanks for taking the time
and hanging out with us.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Thank
you for having us.
MARK MANDEL: A massive amount
of thanks to James and Andrew
for joining us in the sound
booth here at San Francisco
to chat all about
Firebase and I/O with us.
They are doing some
pretty awesome stuff
to grow that platform.
I'm pretty impressed with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, especially very
excited about the
little that they
could share about the future.
But it does sound really cool.
MARK MANDEL: I want to know.
I want to know what's
happening behind the curtain.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
Maybe we could know, actually.
We could ask them and we
just don't tell anyone.
MARK MANDEL: No, we
can't tell anyone.
Well listen, so why don't we
get into this week's Question
of the Week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
the Question of the Week,
it's a pretty simple one but you
know, it's kind of important.
I actually went through
this not that long ago.
So imagine that you
have a project running,
and it's running in production
and there's people using it.
And at some point you
decide that you don't
want to handle it anymore.
So what you want to do is
just give it to someone.
How do you do that?
MARK MANDEL: Like a present.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's more like a pet.
MARK MANDEL: You want
to take care of it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like oh,
now it's yours forever.
MARK MANDEL: Forever.
Cool.
So, well, we've
talked previously
about having IAM, so
Identity Access Management.
But this is actually
like at a high level,
this isn't really
even at a lower level.
This is at a project level.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
there's a variety
of roles you can do with the
Identity Access Management,
or IAM, and one of
them is [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually it
was not that long ago when
we talked about the first
things we ever do with products,
you mentioned that one
of the things that you do
is create a like, "add one
more owner" just in case you
get locked out for
some reason, you
have another way of accessing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So really here
all you need to do
is add that extra person that
you're giving the project to.
Make sure they're an owner,
that's the first step,
then they can go in and make
the changes they need to make.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wait for
them to accept the invitation.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, that's
very, very important.
And the other thing
you'll need to do,
assuming that the payment
method is going to change,
is have them go into
the billing section
and make it switch over
to the payment section
that they're happy with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And then they should remove
you as an owner, and that's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I mean,
they could remove you entirely,
maybe they drop you to an
editor, or a viewer level,
it really depends on exactly how
things are going to go forward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
yeah, it's very simple.
You just need to be careful
making sure that everything
goes on the good steps.
Otherwise you could lock
yourself out and you know,
that's not a good thing to have.
MARK MANDEL: That would be bad.
Exactly.
All right, Francesc.
What are you up to?
What are you doing?
You going anywhere special
in the near future?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
I'm actually going to be,
next week, in Buenos Aires
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
I'm going to Argentina.
It's going to be my
first time in Argentina.
Very, very cool.
I've only been to Chile
before, so my second time
in South America.
I'm going to be speaking at
Google Cloud Onboard, which
is a really cool
event on training.
So you're going to
be able to learn
all of the basics of
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
for the first time ever,
it's going to be live streamed
to all of Latin America.
Check out the links to see how
to access that live stream.
There's a bunch
of viewing parties
all around Latin America.
And it will be in Spanish.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
I'm very excited about that.
It's going to be
in Spanish, but you
know, the same way we have
a bunch of accents here,
it's going to be
in Spanish and I'm
going to have my
Spanish accent-- well,
Catalan accent sometimes.
But we're going to have also a
Cuban accent, Mexican accents,
and it's going to
be lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like
it's going to be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Well I'm going
to go on vacation for a bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good for you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
But it's OK, dear listeners.
I will not be
leaving the podcast.
I will be live and well here.
But yes, I will be going on
vacation for a couple of weeks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't
want to say you deserve it,
but you kind of do.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Thank you, I appreciate that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Enjoy.
Enjoy your holidays.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right, Francesc.
Thank you, yet
again, for joining me
on this episode of the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]